podcasting is the best and that's why p
it can't be stopped because all those
like cancer culture trolls and all that
stuff they're going to keep trying to
come and we're just going to be like
yeah but it's funny because i have a lot
of comics though who didn't do the
podcast thing that say to me
you know that thing's going to die
eventually
oh yeah yeah they they get like they
kind of think it's better
yeah i mean you got it in right around
the right time if i got into it right
now because it's going to die in a
couple years anyway you know i mean
you're like and they try to like
kind of dig at you like you know and
it's like i don't think so
but also it's like and if it does it
does but who's to say we're not going to
jump on the next form of media in our
own way yeah you know like george get on
it whatever the next one is yeah yeah
yeah but you know exactly man but i said
you know what the thing you we have to
get to a point as we've gotten older
bobby is like
we don't need
like when we're right
we don't need these people to say we're
right we just need to be okay with being
right
and that's the hardest thing to do
you're gonna make me cry right now
i'm just saying you've been saying some
more of your [ __ ] today man that's a
good point i was very morphing murphy
[ __ ] today for me like you know i like
morpheus [ __ ] you know and it's like uh
you've been very clear today even at the
little lunch that we had um
but you're right you're absolutely right
um
and
just for the record i will say
that
i can guarantee you
he was the nicest guy to you at lunch
there was no roasting there were no fat
comments none of that because that's who
he is but he cannot it's hard but you
know it's hard what i you know what i
realized today at lunch is we don't do
that enough all right because when i do
see you you have to be on it's like at
the comedy i have okay he's in the
hallway and it's like bob's gotta be
bobby
hallway bobby but that's what we [ __ ]
do you guys know about hallway bobby oh
i know
about it always bobby
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] me about your
name
hey fatty you know i know but i'm so
mean but
but it's all a defensive mechanism right
it's like don't get to know me don't get
demo i'm scared i'm vulnerable you're
just a bunch of [ __ ] i'm going to say
that and i'm still here you're still
here but what i was saying some credit
but at lunch we were talking about that
we need to do more of this because it's
like
you know
am not this i mean i'm an exaggerated
version of who i am there are obviously
elements of me you know i mean that
people see right and that's why when i
go on the road and i meet fans and a lot
of fans
they do i
i know them
podcast fans deeper than any other
medium that i've ever done i know your
podcast fans deeper than
[ __ ] i've been in canada and
people come up to me after the show and
i got tiger belly shirts on and they're
just like oh what's up
you know yeah they take pictures like
we'll do a podcast with you
we should get a percentage of the money
[ __ ]
what i'm saying is like there is
something special about it yeah but it
is also there's an element of toxicity
to it but you know you get the good with
the bad it's a double-edged sword and
we'll take all that because it's been
very you know they're very
it's amazing the fan base yeah i was i
was in brooklyn last week and i was just
walking at a piece of pizza on my hand
and this
bunch of kids just drove by me
and they were like young kids
and they all rolled down their window
and they go
they didn't get out they go
it's not just papaya
like that's right scared and they
and they start laughing and they just
drove away yeah and you know and i had a
tough week last week man and i i walked
down the street with the pizza and i was
just like i needed that
because it wasn't just fans it was like
kids that got it they know the lingo
yeah they kind of know me right and it's
just it's a different a connection you
know but that's the thing too though
that it's like good and bad about it
because that's what i'm saying is like
because i'll have people lit i'm telling
you people walk up to me all the time
and they'll just be like man why is
bobby so mean to you
like
i get that all the time dude yeah yeah
or they'll oh they'll say some [ __ ] like
bobby's not really your friend man why
are you why are you why do you do and i
just go and i gotta say i say it on my
stream all the time i go you don't know
him you don't know us okay you know what
i mean stop i got it right here i'm just
gonna add one thing exhausting if
there's one adjective it is exhausting
if there's one adjective that really
encompasses who he is outside of
performance
is the word harmless he is the most
harmless simpiest sweetest
dude ever
outside when the cameras are off when
it's not hallway bobby he is just a
sweet harmless
yes a quiet little [ __ ]
at home i know the only way to see that
is you have to look on kalila's feed you
know then you catch bobby crying at a
documentary yeah yeah yeah and then
you're just like who the [ __ ] is that
so sensitive
but like ugly crying you know
you will cry i'm all about on youtube
it's have you seen it
oh my god
in fact i want to i want to play it i
cried at the end after this i cried at
the end of black widow what are you
talking about hey why i liked it i like
it i loved black love that movie no i i
thought that that moment that they
shared the sisters
that made me cry i was like all the